herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
ich möchte zu meiner familie in russland
zurückkehren und zwar nicht in einem
sack das sagte ein russischer soldat der
seinen namen nicht aus
sicherheitsgründen verraten will wir
nennen ihn einfach mal dimitri einem
reporter der britischen zeitung guardian
er und andere kameraden hatten sich
anfang april geweigert ein zweites mal
zu einem kampfeinsatz in die ukraine zu
gehen und dimitri ist nicht der einzige
hunderte kommen zu mir hunderte sagt der
russische anwalt und menschenrechtler
michael benn jasch sie wollen nicht
kämpfen sie wollen nicht in diesen krieg
den manche von ihnen fleischwolf ukraine
nennen weil so viele dort sterben und
wenn ja sagt ihnen ja ihr könnt nein
sagen ihr könnt euch weigern ohne ins
gefängnis zu gehen wir haben jetzt die
großartige chance mit ihm zu sprechen
mit diesem anwalt mit michael peña und
von ihnen wollen wir erfahren wie es den
russischen soldaten geht wie es um die
kampfmoral der russischen soldaten
bestellt ist herr michael peña schönen
guten abend vielen dank dass sie mit
unserer
gut
ja es ist eine tolle sache dass wir mit
ihnen reden können dass wir ihnen fragen
stellen können und wenn sie eben fragen
haben dann einfach her damit wir wollen
sie weiterleiten und sind alle gespannt
auf die antworten von herrn wenn jetzt
zunächst aber ein überblick über die
moral den zustand der russischen truppen
über schein und sein der russischen
armee
sie sind bekannt diese bilder und sie
verfehlen ihre wirkung nicht auf namen
des russischen militärs dies in seiner
ganzen größe und bedrohlichkeit zeigen
wie zuletzt bei der siegerparade zum
neunten mai in moskau
fast drei monate nach beginn des krieges
in der ukraine sind es aber auch
solcherlei bilder die sich mittlerweile
einprägen ausgebrannte und
zurückgelassene russische panzer am
wegesrand der krieg darin sind sich die
meisten beobachter einig ist für die
russische armee bei weitem nicht so
gelaufen ist geplant war
entsprechend häufen sich die berichte
über die zunehmende demoralisierung
innerhalb der truppe die stammen zum
teil von ukrainischer seite wird diese
aussage eines russischen
kriegsgefangenen der behauptet und der
androhung von gefängnis zum einsatz in
der ukraine gezwungen worden zu sein
dies ist selbstverständlich genauso
wenig nachprüfbar wie dieses video eines
russischen soldaten der berichtet die er
und seine kameraden zurückgelassen
wurden und sich selbst als kanonenfutter
bezeichnet
oder dieser soldat in den händen der
ukraine der weinend mit seiner mutter
telefoniert
insgesamt scheint sich aber auch in
russland ein bild zu formen dass
wehrpflichtige mit sorge erfüllt ohne
ausreichende militärische ausbildung an
der front eingesetzt zu werden dazu gibt
es immer mehr berichte auch von
berufssoldaten die den ukraine einsatz
verweigern
ich bin ja sie vertreten sie helfen
russischen soldaten die nicht kämpfen
wollen was sind das für soldaten und was
berichten die was erzählen die
[Musik]
sie haben mir ganz unterschiedliche
motive
ganz ganz
unterschiedliche
ich kann das überhaupt nicht
verallgemeinern ich verstehe was sie von
mir hören wollen
dass die moral sehr tief gesunken ist
das kann ich nicht bestätigen
ich bin ja kein
mensch der direkt involviert ist ich war
selbst nicht an der front
ich
konnte mich nicht mit eigenen augen mit
eigenen ohren nicht überzeugen wie es
mit der moral bestellt ist ich kann
ihnen nur darüber berichten was meiner
kundschaft mehr sagt was meine mandanten
mir berichten anteil von ihnen
will einfach ihr leben nicht riskieren
zu den konditionen t in dem
vertriebsvertrag stehen ein anderer teil
wird will einfach überhaupt nicht mit
dieser operation zu tun haben bei dort
menschen erschossen werden und das wird
von ihnen verlangt
einige sind absolut nicht damit
zufrieden
welche garantien sie in russland
bekommen es gibt verschiedene motive für
diese verweigerung sowohl
pazifistisch auf der einen seite als
auch rein
kommerziell auf der anderen
was wir jetzt auf den ukrainischen
internetseiten sehen ist er echt
erschreckend
jetzt habe ich aber eben das ist das was
wir bekannt ist genau jetzt gibt es ja
einerseits soldaten die nicht zum ersten
mal in die ukraine wollen die eben wie
sie sagen dann nicht kämpfen wollen gar
nicht die waffe auf ukraine richten
wollen etc es gibt ja aber eben auch
leute wie eben dieser dimitri die sagen
ich war in der ukraine oder meine
einheit war da dann sind wir wieder
zurückgezogen worden und ich will nicht
ein zweites mal dahin das heißt die
soldaten die wie dimitri halt schon mal
einen angriff in der ukraine
miterlebt haben was berichten die denn
ihnen gegenüber so dass sie ja
vielleicht doch auch ein bild bekommen
was in der ukraine passiert wir hören ja
immer nur indirekt über logistische
probleme die ist und dass im beitrag
haben das gehört dass möglicherweise
auch manchmal soldaten zurückgelassen
werden etc für uns ist das äußerst
schwer sich ein bild zu machen aber sie
hören ja auch vielleicht beschreibungen
eben von soldaten die ja in der ukraine
schon im einsatz war
ich kann ihnen nicht hier wiedergeben
was
meine mandanten mir berichten und zwar
aus vielerlei gründen
zum einen haben nicht alle dem
zugestimmt dass ich solche informationen
an die massenmedien weitergeben
sollte ich
dagegen
verstoßen laufe ich die gefahr
nach dem russischen gesetz
entsprechend dem artikel wegen der
diskreditierung der russischen armee zur
verortung gezogen zu werden ich kann
ihnen allgemein sagen grundsätzlich sind
die mir bekannten
aussagen der russischen soldaten
und durchaus
dementsprechend
zu bezeichnen als was wie auf diesen
bildern sehen
obwohl wir in unserem land ja keine
bestimmten keine direkten bestätigungen
dafür haben und zu sehen bekommen
bleiben wir also auf absoluten sicherem
terrain wir haben verstanden was das
problem ist kommen wir aber zu der
juristischen sache die sie eben bestens
beantworten können als anwalt droht
diesen soldaten die sich weigern
einmarschbefehl auszufüllen in die
ukraine zu ziehen die sagen nein ich
will nicht dahin ich verweigere den
befehl droht denen denn jetzt nicht
schwerste strafe oder wie sieht es aus
hier ist zu wenig
wenn ein rekrut
sich weigert einen einsatz vertrag zu
unterzeichnen
droht ihm gar nichts ja er hat er
riskiert gar nichts dabei sollte ihm
tatsächlich
im nachhinein etwas dadurch entstehen
dann ist das tatsächlich einer
gesetzesverletzung
es ist tatsächlich ein bruch der
russischen vorschriften der sogar der
russische präsident hat befohlen und
verfügt dass bei junge rekruten nicht an
die front geschickt werden es ist ja
rechtlich überhaupt nicht möglich jemand
zu zwingend so einen einsatz vertrag zu
unterzeichnen
deswegen rufen wir appellieren jetzt zu
allen rekruten diese verträge nicht zu
unterzeichnen es ist gesetzeswidrig es
ist illegal wenn ein
offizier jemand zwingt einen solchen
vertrag zu unterzeichnen ist das
amtsmissbrauch
was nur diejenigen betrifft die
berufssoldaten sind und einen solchen
vertrag bereits in der tasche haben und
ihn unterschreiben haben dann ist es
rechtlich gesehen ein ganz anderer fall
ich glaube
in zu 100 prozent sind das fälle dabei
dass im falle einer verweigerung und
zwar dieses einsatzes in der ukraine
werden die menschen aus der armee
entlassen
und diese entlassung aus den reihen der
streitkräfte ist ebenfalls illegal dies
gesetzeswidrig
wenn es dazu kommen dass
die soldaten
wenn sie direkt an der front sind einen
marschbefehl verweigern oder einen
befehl verweigern so können daraus auch
folgen entstehen und zwar eine
kriminelle verfolgung tatsächlich je
nach der schwere
dieser tat dieses schrittes
diejenigen die zurzeit in der ukraine
sind und zwei der russischen armee in
den russischen streitkräften
müssen von dir das licht lädt das direkt
erfahren dass es nicht ungefährlich ist
einen befehl dort direkt an der front zu
verweigern
die
verfolgung besteht jedoch zum
zum größten teil aus sagen wir kleineren
strafen
es droht keinem der einen solchen
befehle und einsatz an der front
verwehrt die 15 jahre gefängnis aber
erklären wir würde ich das kleben
schilderten genau und herr bannasch
erklären sie ganz kurz zum verständnis
nur zwei dinge aber was ist der grund
hängt das damit zusammen dass putin das
ganze als spezial operation erklärt hat
und nicht als krieg als verteidigung der
russischen föderation des heimatlandes
und erklären sie noch ganz kurz wenn sie
rekruten sagen meinen sie dann
wehrpflichtige also als gegensatz zu
berufssoldaten
ja ja ja ja ja zum zweiten auf jeden
fall der rekruten meine ich ja natürlich
wehrpflichtigen im gegensatz
zu den berufssoldaten und es gibt ja
eingesetzt
der russischen föderation aber
unterschiedlicher handhabe
nach dem russischen gesetz können
wehrpflichtige nur an die front
geschickt werden nachdem sie vollständig
ausgebildet sind nachdem der einen
vollständigen
ausbildungszeit raum
durchlaufen das ist nicht verboten
laut gesetz dagegen hat putin offiziell
öffentlich
befohlen und das ist ja überall im
internet zu finden
keine
wehrpflichtigen an die front zu schicken
und er ist ja der oberbefehlshaber und
dieser befehl gilt für alle der
kommandos und für alle offiziere und das
ist
gültig jetzt
das ist ein punkt genau den hat immer
gesagt keine wehrpflichtigen an die
front was wäre aber jetzt wenn putin
hingehen würde und würde sagen ja ich
schicke doch wehrpflichtige an die front
wäre das dann sozusagen eine lösung dass
er auf einmal dann neue frische truppen
hätte oder gäbe es dann das problem dass
eben diese wehrpflicht liegen noch gar
nicht richtig ausgebildet sind dass man
am ende sagen kann dann müsste man
wirklich von kanonenfutter sprechen
wehrpflichtige die eben gar nicht
vollständig ausgebildet sind weil die
professionellen ausbilder selbst an der
front sind dann eben dorthin geschickt
werden und noch gar nicht sozusagen reif
für die front sind ausgebildet sind
letztendlich auch
gegen das gesetz gegen das goethe
gerecht dass jemand ohne
ausbildung an die front ein landwirt
sollte putin
tatsächlich jetzt seinen befehl
ändern
so würde das dem gesetz nicht
widersprechen das ist ja tatsächlich ja
die noch im rahmen des gesetzes dass er
das würde dazu führen dass putin
seine unterstützung in der bevölkerung
unendlich viel verliert und das würde
ihm selbst schaden aber letztendlich
machen die ja die er via kommandos genau
dasselbe schon die holen jetzt solche
wehrpflichtige 1
aber was zeigt dass wenn selbst
wehrpflichtige trotz des versprechens
oder der ankündigung von putin keine
wehrpflichtigen einzusetzen eingezogen
werden was zeigt dass oder was sind kann
man dem entnehmen das ist wirklich
personal not gibt russischen militär
ich bin leider kein militärexperte
angaben seitens des
verteidigungsministeriums
der russischen föderation sind äußerst
dürftig
die haben keine aussagekraft
ich kann ihnen diese frage wirklich
nicht beantworten
ganz ehrlich ich denke meiner meinung
wird auch keine rolle spielen
so der richtigen bewertung zu kommen
fragen sie lieber echte militärexperten
ja
es gibt einen militärexperten andré
kolesnikov der hat gesagt wenn putin
eine generalmobilmachung
anordnen würde was er ja bisher nicht
getan hat auch nicht am 9 deshalb haben
wir ja alle sehr gespannt auf diesen
sieges tag den neunten mal geschaut ob
putin eben bei seiner rede vielleicht
von einer generalmobilmachung spricht er
hat es nicht getan andrej kolesnikow
sagte wenn putin eine
generalmobilmachung anordnen würde dann
könnte es zum konflikt mit denjenigen
kommen die bisher diese spezialoperation
in anführungsstrichen in der ukraine
zwar befürworten aber selbst nicht
kämpfen wollen heißt das dass putin also
zögert diese karte irgendwie
auszuspielen weil eben dann diejenigen
die bisher damit einverstanden sind
diese operationen in anführungsstrichen
befürworten auf einmal umschwenken
könnte nahm sie da so ein bauchgefühl
alles klar
ich habe bereits gesagt
dass die wehrpflichtigen
letztendlich wenn sie in die ukraine
ernannt werden und immer mehr
verpflichtet werden dazu führen
wird dass
die umfrage der daten von putin
stark abfallen würden und die ganze
staatliche propaganda ist nicht imstande
gegen aldi
gegenmeinungen aus der bevölkerung gegen
die gemeinde der mütter gegen die fragen
der mütter direkte söder ihrer der
frauen die ihrer ehemänner fall verloren
haben entgegen zu wirken
ja seine popularität wird eindeutig
einbrechen und kolles nico vater
vollkommen recht
dann letzte frage sie haben sie gerade
selbst erwähnt die mütter der soldaten
die russische propaganda läuft ja nun
auf hochtouren im staatsfernsehen gibt
es nicht sehr viel kritisches was in der
ukraine passiert sie selbst haben ja
auch gesagt zahlen die genannt werden
sind da nicht unbedingt verlässlich was
erfahren denn die menschen am ende und
sie kriegen es ja doch ein bisschen
indirekt damit kommen doch bilder in
russland an erfahren eben mütter väter
verwandte eltern
dann doch was mit ihren söhnen in der
ukraine passiert wie sieht das aus
welche informationen bekommen am ende
dann doch die familien und verwandten
von russischen soldaten
ich glaube ein
geistig gesunder mensch kann
überhaupt kein russisches fernsehen
überhaupt
einschalten ich muss das leider
beruflich des öfteren machen aber das
ist ja so eine qual das ist so ein
krampf das zu tun
es ist einfach katastrophal
ich
würde behaupten dass man ja etwas
zuverlässiges cloud würde jetzt nur im
internet findet beziehungsweise auf
internetseiten die ihr unabhängig und
oppositionell sind
ich glaube mir ist das nicht die
russische propaganda läuft auf vollen
touren ja es ist viel geld hineingepumpt
worden
und sie erreicht tatsächlich
jeden und alle
es ist auch viel
hass
zu beobachten auch gegenüber der
russischen bevölkerung
und die
propagandisten
versuchen auch ihrerseits auch gegen die
anderen völker anderen länder
hineinzupumpen und ich versichere ihnen
nicht alle unterstützen putin wir sind
nicht so wie wir dargestellt werden wir
werden ständig verfolgt sobald wir was
anderes sagen sobald wir sobald wir
entgegenwirken ich bitte sie nicht zu
glauben dass wir tatsächlich alle für
die machthaber sind dann danken wir ganz
ganz ganz herzlich für diese eindrücke
für diese informationen und doch
wirklich einblicke die man jetzt ohne
sie nicht bekommen hätte und ich kann
ganz schnell einfach nur ein kompliment
weitergeben denn unsere zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer paul schreibt sie über
youtube respekt dass er ben ja überhaupt
ein interview wagt er fragt gibt es
eigentlich weitere anwälte wie sie in
russland und sandra dampf schreibt über
e-mail als e-mail guten abend vorab ich
finde den gesprächspartner sehr
interessant und bedanke mich dafür dass
wir das live verfolgen können also
insofern ein großes großes dankeschön
von allen und eben auch von uns direkt
an sie dass wir dieses gespräch mit
ihnen machen konnten vielen vielen dank
herr bin ja
ich grüße zurück und alles gute für sie
ja soweit das gespräch mit herrn den
asche und jetzt wollen wir mit claudia
mayor von der stiftung wissenschaft und
politik reden die expertin für
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik ist
frau major hatte das gespräch mit
michael bin ja aufmerksam mitverfolgt
was sagen sie denn hat russland aus
ihrer sicht aus ihrem von ihrem
beobachtungspunkt aus sozusagen ein
personalproblem mangelt es den
russischen truppen wirklich an soldaten
die einfach weglaufen sich weigern und
sagen nein ich gehe nicht in diesen
krieg
von dem was wir von offiziellen wissen
von offiziellen quellen wissen hat die
russische armee etwa ein drittel der
eingesetzten truppen verloren entweder
weise gefallen sind weil sie dezitiert
sind weil weise gefangen genommen worden
sind man sieht auch dass die truppen
durch diesen sehr langen kampf ein satz
einfach abgenutzt und ausgelaugt sind
und sich die frage gestellt inwieweit
sie noch mal neu zusammengesetzt neu
aufgebaut werden können das heißt es
sind in der tat tatsächlich so aus als
hätte die russische armee ein
personalproblem
und dabei geht es auch nicht nur um
kampftruppen sondern wenn man einen
erfolgreichen einsatz haben will dann
muss man auch an so etwas wie sanität
oder logistik denken und das kann man
nicht so einfach mit wehrpflichtigen
oder reservisten auffüllen
jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen raus
gehört oder kann es sein dass wir das
richtig raus gehört haben dass putin so
ein bisschen in dem dilemma steckt es
ist ein geschickter schachzug zu sagen
es ist eine spezialoperation in der
ukraine jene ein kleiner militärischer
eingriff um da wie er ja gesagt hat eben
nazis zu beseitigen das regime zu
beseitigen etc und damit teile der
bevölkerung auf seine seite zu ziehen
sie sagt ja ja ist schon richtig um eine
generalmobilmachung zu vermeiden
andererseits kriegen wir ja gerade mit
das gibt die möglichkeit ja eben auch zu
sagen nee da mache ich nicht mit und das
ist eine ganz andere sache wenn
kriegsrecht herrscht aber eben krieg
offiziell ausrufen will putin nicht ist
das so eine bredouille in der steckt
das ist unheimlich schwer einzuschätzen
weil es auch sehr schwer einzuschätzen
ist welche kommunikation in der doch
sehr stark kontrollierten russischen
öffentlichkeit wirklich funktioniert wir
haben in der rede am neunten mai zum
sieges tag schon gesehen dass das putin
dieses diesen diesen krieg immer mehr
fremd in einen konflikt mit dem westen
mit der nato also was was genau verfängt
ist schwer zu sagen
tatsächlich wenn sie jetzt russland von
einem wirklichen krieg reden würde dann
müsste man auch eingestehen dass das ein
bisschen größer und schwieriger ist als
bislang gedacht aber was genau welches
narrativ genau in russland wie verfängt
ist von außen unheimlich schwer
einzuschätzen aber könnte das platt
gesprochen tatsächlich am ende zum
problem werden für putin wenn ihm die
soldaten weglaufen desertieren wir haben
ja nun auch bilder gesehen dass sie
einfach dann den panzer stehen lassen er
keinen sprit mehr hat und sagen komm wir
gehen nach hause und andere melden sich
bei michael wenni asche und sagen ich
will da gar nicht erst hin
na klar das ist ein riesengroßes problem
wir haben von anfang an in diesem krieg
gesehen dass wir wahrscheinlich auch
vorher die russische armee überschätzt
haben das heißt wir haben sehr große
schwächen gesehen die viele überrascht
haben nicht eingegriffen das war die
kampfkraft das war die ihn fragen wovon
logistik das waren die fragen der moral
der truppe auch das heißt es gab mehrere
schwachstellen die man auch nicht so
einfach überwinden kann die russischen
truppen haben sich neu aufgestellt es
gab auch eine reorganisation der
kommandostrukturen beispielsweise aber
insgesamt gab es von anfang an dieses
krieges viele schwächen die wir gesehen
haben und die sich erst langfristig
lösen können und die moral also
sozusagen wie engagiert und wie sehr
glauben die soldaten auch an diesen
einsatz das war von anfang an ein großes
problem und das setzt sich fort und ja
das ist eine sehr große schwäche der
russische name jetzt haben wir
besprochen wir haben es auch live gehört
für mich wenn ja viele russische
soldaten haben die schrecken des krieges
erlebt laufen weg weigern sich weil sie
nicht noch mal in diesen krieg wollen
weil sie nicht noch mal in die ukraine
marschieren wollen es gibt aber auch ein
ganz besonderes schicksal eines
russischen soldaten und zwar das
schicksal eines jungen russen der
gefangen genommen wurde und der nun vor
einem ukrainischen gericht verurteilt
worden ist wegen kriegsverbrechen
auch reue und das geständnis halfen am
ende nichts lebenslang für fahrdienste
marien der 21 jährige russische soldat
hatte einem ukrainischen zivilisten in
den kopf geschossen es war der erste
kriegsverbrecherprozess seit der
russischen invasion weitere werden
folgen dafür wollen russische exil
journalistin auf spurensuche in der
ukraine sorgen die reporterin lilija
paravent etwa berichtet für eine
russischsprachige webseite mit sitz in
lettland
manchmal tut es weh zu schreiben weil
ich keine fakten verbergen kann aber
komme ich dafür ins gefängnis
allein die bezeichnung der invasion als
krieg könnte sie in russland mit bis zu
15 jahren gefängnis bezahlen japano will
trotzdem weitermachen das asus stahlwerk
in mariupol explosionen kommen hier
jetzt nur noch von kontrollierten
sprengungen durch russische soldaten das
weitere schicksal der verteidiger die
sich ergeben haben ist unklar offenbar
ist auch ein austausch mit russischen
gefangenen denkbar heißt es aus dem
russischen außenministerium
in mariupol hat russland den
wochenlangen widerstand gebrochen in der
region doch jetzt ist das hingegen noch
nicht gelungen
die sind auf jede entwicklung der
ereignisse vorbereitet wir sind zum
angriff zur verteidigung und wenn nötig
zum rückzug bereit
auf beiden seiten gibt es hohe verluste
weit mehr als zehntausend russische
soldaten sollen schon umgekommen sein
schätzt der britische geheimdienst das
wären mehr als die sowjetunion in zehn
jahren afghanistan krieg verloren hat
also diese zahl diese schätzung 10
tausend russische soldaten gefallen das
klingt ja schon viel das klingt ja schon
heftig nach ukrainischen angaben seien
es sogar
27.000 die letzte offizielle russische
zahl die wir zumindest gelesen haben
über gefallener soldaten stammt vom 25
märz seitdem haben wir zumindest jetzt
keine aktuellen zahlen von russischer
seite gelesen die liegt bei
1351 ist also äußerst schwierig und sie
haben es ja gesagt es gibt manche
britische quellen die sagen ein drittel
der im februar eingesetzten bodenkampf
truppen seien verloren was bedeutet dass
am ende alles wie verlässlich sind diese
zahlen und was bedeutet dass letzten
endes für russland
also wir haben von anfang an an diesem
krieg gesehen dass er sich sehr
dynamisch entwickelt
russland hatte gehofft dass innerhalb
von zwei tagen kiew überrannt die
ukraine überrannt und kiew eingenommen
ist und wir sind jetzt drei monate in
diesem krieg und die ukraine hat viel
geländegewinne gutmachen können russland
hat sich vor kiew zurückziehen müssen
und konzentriert sich jetzt auf dem
osten in den bars und auf diese
landbrücke von dem don was drüber bis
zur halbinsel krim das heißt wir sehen
dass die ukraine sich deutlich besser
geschlagen hat als gedacht und man muss
ganz klar sagen dass die westlichen
staaten den kriegsverlauf mitbestimmen
können und zwar durch durch drei
verschiedene sachen einmal die
sanktionen die russland schwächen die
militärische unterstützung für die
ukraine die sukzessive immer stärker
geworden ist und auch die ganze andere
nicht militärische hilfe das heißt die
finanzielle hilfe humanitäre hilfe für
die ukraine das heißt wie es weitergeht
hängt zu großen teilen auch davon ab wie
die westlichen staaten die ukraine
weiter unterstützen jetzt mobilisiert
kiew seit monaten werden wir über
mobilisierung moral der truppe personal
gesprochen kiew die ukraine mobilisieren
nun seit monaten immer neue truppen
können also diese neuen frischen truppen
mit waffen aus dem westen zum beispiel
eben in die ost ukraine schicken und die
frage wäre könnte diesen truppen das
gleiche gelingen wie vor wenigen wochen
eben den ukrainern rundum kiew dass sie
am ende die russischen angreifenden
truppen auch wieder zurückwerfen aus dem
land zurück drängen
also dem carina hat jetzt gerade die
generalmobilmachung verlängert jetzt
auch das kriegsrecht verlängert und geht
davon aus dass der krieg mindestens bis
zum herbst dauern wird geplant ist eine
offensive im juni im sommer und da ist
die hoffnung dass die ukrainischen
truppen tatsächlich russland
substanziell zurückgreifen können noch
mal der krieg ist der dynamisch ist es
sehr schwer das vorherzusagen aber so
wie es jetzt aussieht wenn die
unterstützung durch den westen bleibt in
den verschiedenen bereichen militärisch
aber auch finanziell und mit blick auf
die sanktionen gegen russland und
russland weiterhin diese ermüdung und
verschleißerscheinungen zeigt die es
jetzt schon zeigt dann ist durchaus
vorstellbar dass die ukraine gebiete die
russland seit dem 24 zwei gesetzt hat
zurückerobern kann das wird nicht leicht
wie gesagt es hängt auch sehr stark
davon ab wie viel von der schweren
ausrüstung also art der gepanzerte
fahrzeuge flugabwehr die ukraine noch
kriegen kann aber sie steht von den
tropen her deutlich besser da und sie
hat hoffentlich die gesicherte auch
langfristig gesicherte westliche
unterstützung schauen wir allerdings mal
auf die aktuelle lage wir haben das auch
im beitrag schon gesehen die russen
haben mariupol vollständig eingenommen
dass es oft stahlwerk auch die letzte
ukrainische kämpfer jetzt dort
aufgegeben im süden sie haben selbst
gesagt steht diese landverbindung
zwischen der krim und russland sprich
dieser ganze streifen an der küste
entlang am asowschen meer ist in
russischer hand und damit ist dort die
ukraine also abgeschnitten vom asowschen
meer und in der region lohans sieht es
im moment so aus dass 90 prozent des
territoriums jetzt unter kontrolle von
pro separatisten oder dem militär aus
russland eben ist kann man denn sagen
dass wenn wir jetzt auf den osten und
den südosten eben gucken dass moment
doch russland geländegewinne gemacht die
ukraine zurückdrängt uns sind die
ukrainischen truppen der in der
defensive oder sagen sie wirklich das
blatt kann sich da wieder wenden
momentan ist tatsächlich so dass
russland noch kleine gewinne macht und
dann gerade im süden sich dort
konsolidiert und de facto eingreift und
das versucht fakten zu schaffen auf dem
boden in der region das heißt es sendet
die signale aus wir sind gekommen um zu
bleiben beispielsweise indem der gugl
eingeführt wird in dem das ukrainische
fernsehen abgestellt wird in dem es zur
deportation kommt auch der ukrainischen
bevölkerung und neben de facto einer
ossifizierung versucht wird das heißt
russland versucht gerade in dieser
region fakten zu schaffen aber in die
frage ist der faktor wann diese
russische
der russische vormarsch de facto an der
stoppt und wann es gibt und wann sie
mehr in eine defensive wandeln und
nochmal das ist wird vermutet jetzt wenn
die ukraine in eine sommeroffensive etwa
im juni starten könnte und versuchen
könnte dann die russischen truppen
zurück zu werfen und wie sieht es aus
soweit ich enormen ist ja schon ein
beispiel dafür dass russische truppen
wieder bis zur landesgrenze im grunde
genommen zurückgedrängt worden sind
richtig
ja also wir können mehrere beispiele wo
ist die ukraine gelungen ist wieder
geländegewinne zu machen momentan ist
das alles nicht sehr signifikant das
momentan sind das eher kleinere gewinne
auf beiden seiten aber die frage ist wie
gesagt wie sich das langfristig ändern
wird wenn in russland der verschleiß der
truppen das problem dass sie die nicht
mehr aufstellen können dass sie wenig
nachschub haben dass die bekannten
probleme von logistik bis zur moral
immer noch fort bleiben wie sich das
auswirkt im vergleich zu chronischen
truppen die sich neu aufstellen können
die unterstützung aus dem westen kriegen
also wie sich dieses kräfteverhältnis
langfristig auswirken wird und da gehen
mittlerweile viele beobachter davon aus
dass es zu gunsten der ukraine kippen
kann jetzt haben sie gerade gesagt immer
so ein bisschen auch unter der
voraussetzung wie es aussieht mit
waffenlieferung aus dem westen jetzt
kriegen wir gerade die frage rein von
marie delhi nun acht über youtube
geschäftsfrau major denn die deutsche
verzögerung der schweren waffenlieferung
ein verlängert das nicht den krieg
unnötig noch mal zum punkt deutschland
hat ja
wäre waffen hat panzer versprochen aber
stand heute wird heute nochmal auch
gemeldet glasklar von den 30 gepard flac
panzern sollen aber nur 15 bis mitte
juli geliefert werden der rest dann bis
ende august da fragt man sich ja schon
genau wie marie delhi 08 reicht das oder
kommt dass nicht alles viel zu spät
das ist in der tat bedauerlich dass ist
da diese verzögerungen gibt
zum glück liefern auch noch andere nato
staaten
man muss aber auch sagen es gibt so ein
kleines gap zwischen dem was deutschland
wirklich liefert und macht und da liegen
wir gar nicht so schlecht im vergleich
auch zu großbritannien und frankreich
aber die kommunikation und die
organisationen diesmal halt wirklich
nicht gut ich glaube die frage die wir
uns dahinter viel mehr stellen müssen
ist wie wir eine langfristige
systematische unterstützung der ukraine
sicherstellen können und dass wir nicht
immer nur so von einer
einzelentscheidung zur nächsten hoppeln
sondern überlegen wie kann man das
langfristig systematisch sichern und
erst der erste schritt der jetzt ja
schon seit mehreren wochen und der weg
ist zu sagen wir liefern die westlichen
staaten gemeinsam liefern vor allem das
alte sowjetische material wie die t 72
panzer die die ukraine sofort einsetzen
kann weil sie darauf ausgebildet ist
parallel dazu das beginnt jetzt auch
schon oder hat schon begonnen die
ausbildung an westlichen material
beispielsweise der panzerhaubitze 2000
was auch in deutschland stattfindet oder
an französischen systemen am britischen
amerikanischen system die dann
sukzessive in die ukrainischen
streitkräfte eingeführt werden weil die
wirklich einen substanziellen
unterschied machen also artillerie
gepanzerte fahrzeuge und langfristig
muss man fragen wie auch die
industriekapazitäten darauf ausgelegt
werden können die ukraine zu
unterstützen bei munition oder auch bei
ausrüstung das heißt die frage ist wie
können wir die ukraine an einem
langfristigen szenario unterstützen was
wir jetzt schon schon planen und jetzt
schon unterstützen können also wie
gesagt jetzt ausbilden an den westlichen
systemen damit ihr dann schnell
eingeführt werden können und das ist das
wo die europäer de facto
zusammenarbeiten müssen das läuft ganz
gut am beispiel der panzerhaubitze 2000
weil deutschland mit den niederlanden
zusammenarbeitet aber das müssen wir in
allen bereichen noch systematischer
machen das funktioniert jetzt seit der
konferenz und rammstein wo sich die
verschiedenen geber absprechen wollen
aber das müssen wir wirklich von anfang
an mit denken gemeinsam
und langfristig systematischer
unterstützung jetzt haben sie
passenderweise mehrfach die
panzerhaubitze
2000 erwähnt ich glaube ich lege nicht
falsch wenn ich sage das ist gehört
zudem zu der kategorie schwere waffen
und ich glaube ich lege auch nicht ganz
falsch wenn man sagt die panzerhaubitze
ist made in germany also hier im westen
produziert und nicht ein alter t was
weiß ich panzer der geliefert wird und
jetzt gibt es neue verwirrung nämlich
nach einem zdf interview von berlin
direkt mit einer staatssekretär im
verteidigungsministerium
da stellt sich die frage jetzt moment
mal wie ist das denn mit schweren waffen
und der lieferung und was wurde
versprochen ist das jetzt alles
irgendwie gegen nato vereinbarungen wird
und wer hat recht schauen wir uns das
mal gemeinsam an
sie sind nicht die modernsten aber sie
sind aus dem westen vor gut vier wochen
beginnen die usa 200 schützenpanzer 113
für die ukraine zu verladen die
amerikaner liefern was laut
bundesregierung eigentlich
ausgeschlossen sein sollte es ist eine
einheitliche position nicht nur
innerhalb der bundesregierung sondern
auch innerhalb der westlichen nationen
keine schützenpanzer oder kampfpanzer
westlichen modells zu liefern so erklärt
die ampelkoalition warum der 50 jahre
alte schützenpanzer marder nicht auch
geliefert wird in einem bericht des
verteidigungsministeriums heißt es
nämlich 32 marder könnten zeitnah
instandgesetzt und genutzt werden so ein
medienbericht der sprecher des
verteidigungsministeriums bestätigt
diese bisher nicht kommunizierte nato
position es war ja nicht die rede von
einer formalen übereinkunft oder
ähnliches fakt ist dass das bisher noch
nicht geschehen ist und können sie davon
ausgehen dass dass die nato-partner so
sehen sonst wäre es ja kein
widerspruch denn gemeinsam mit den
niederlanden liefert deutschland 12
panzerhaubitzen 2000 an die ukraine
westlicher bauart und das modernste
artilleriegeschütz derzeit weltweit die
opposition ist irritiert mit großer
mehrheit hat der deutsche bundestag
beschlossen dass man waffen zur stärkung
der selbstverteidigung in die ukraine
liefern will auch schwere waffen
explizit da scheint es sich wohl um hier
ein missverständnis oder eine
verwechslung zu handeln us soldaten
richten weiter panzer für die ukraine
her
halten sich die amerikaner nicht an die
nato verabredung oder gibt es sie
vielleicht gar nicht es bleiben mehr
fragen als antworten
tja frau major verstehen sie diesen
hick-hack
also was wir sehen können es seit beginn
des krieges dass sich die nato staaten
und die westlichen staaten sukzessive
weiterentwickelt haben am anfang hat
keiner von panzerhaubitzen oder
ähnlichen gesprochen und je weiter der
krieg ging und je mehr klar oder dass
die ukraine tatsächlich mit westlicher
unterstützung widerstehen kann desto
mehr haben sich auch die westlichen
staaten entwickelt und es ging hin zu
immer mehr und immer schwerere material
und auch westliche material das heißt
die linie ist ist da und es gibt auch
also es gibt bereits ehemalige sowjet
panzer die geliefert werden die 72 und
es gibt westliche gepanzerte fahrzeuge
die geliefert werden das heißt es liegt
in der regel im ermessen der einzelnen
nato-staaten was sie liefern und da
haben viele von den westlichen staaten
westliches material wie beispielsweise
die franzosen mit dem at t systems cesar
bereits deutlich westliche system
vorgelegt deshalb glaube ich
versteh ich nicht so richtig was da der
widerspruch sein soll aber
eine ganz interessante frage die jetzt
hier gekommen ist von dieselpumpe über
youtube frage an die militärische seite
wie gelingt es denn dem westen überhaupt
waffen also jetzt nehmen wir mal die
panzerhaubitze 2000 oder nehmen wir dann
eben im juli
den gepard den fleck panzer diese waffen
in die ukraine zu bekommen an die front
am ende zu transportieren ohne dass die
russischen satelliten diese entdecken
und die russische armee sage ich mal
durch die luftwaffe am ende diese
lieferungen diese panzer dann zerstört
also wir sind bislang über polen an die
ukraine geliefert worden und es hat
bislang gut funktioniert wir müssen aber
auch sagen dass russland bislang eine
eskalation mit den nato staaten
vermieden hat das heißt sie haben
bislang dieser transportrouten nicht
substanziell unter beschuss genommen
oder versucht dieses zu unterbinden das
heißt die gefahr dass
sie sagen dann damit angriffe auf nato
territorium auf polen beispielsweise
drohnen wurden hat sich bislang nicht
bewahrheitet
jetzt noch eine frage die auch sozusagen
frisch kommt weil der cdu-außenpolitiker
kiesewetter gestern den kurs der
bundesregierung wir haben ja gerade
drüber gesprochen kommen die
waffenlieferungen zu spät ist das ein
hinhalten wie ernst ist das oder ist es
eben auch nur kommunikation wie sie
sagen wenn man auch mal auf die anderen
verbündeten schaut aber er zumindest
kiesewetter hat eben kanzler scholz
vorgeworfen zu zögerlich zu sein und auf
zeit zu spielen und er sagte gestern in
der ard
die deutsche industrie hat bereits am 28
februar deutlich gemacht dass sie sehr
rasch um die 100 leopard panzer und um
die 100 marder ertüchtigen könnte bis
heute gebe es aber keinen auftrag ich
denke da spielt der kanzler auf zeit wie
sehen sie das
ich kann zumindest die außenwahrnehmung
beschreiben und die außenwahrnehmung war
dass das innerhalb der koalition
verschiedene positionen gab dass
beispielsweise die ausschussvorsitzenden
toni hofreiter marie agnes strack
zimmermann und michael roth sehr klar
schwere waffen geliefert haben und das
ist nicht umgesetzt worden also von
außen ist der eindruck entstanden dass
es keine unterschiede in der koalition
gab und unsere partner gerade in mittel
und osteuropa also die baltischen
staaten und polen haben das auch
wahrgenommen und haben sich so ein
bisschen gewundert warum deutschland als
ein so großes politisch militärisch und
wirtschaftlich wichtiges land sich nicht
mehr geregt hat das heißt deutschland
unterstützt der ukraine zwar sehr stark
aber es wird von außen nicht so
wahrgenommen und das ist zum teil wie
gesagt auch ein kommunikationsfehler und
das hat dazu geführt dass es gerade bei
unseren verbündeten viele fragen über
unsere verlässlichkeit gab und viele
fragen
wo wir eigentlich stehen und das ist
außerordentlich bedauerlich ich glaube
die frage ist wirklich wie kann man das
nach vorne drehen und wie kann man jetzt
diese systematische unterstützung auf
dem weg bringen wie ich vorhin
angesprochen hatte und wie kann man das
auch verbinden zu sagen mit der
kooperation mit unseren partnern
es gibt in vielen ländern noch die
panzerhaubitze 2000 beispielsweise auch
in italien gibt es da
kooperationsmöglichkeiten also ich
glaube man soll jetzt gucken wie man das
nach vorne dreht und guckt wie kann man
es in zukunft besser machen und wie kann
man die ukraine im bereich der schweren
waffen unterstützen aber auch in all den
anderen bereichen wo sie unterstützung
braucht beispielsweise treibstoff
russland hat systematisch die
treibstofflager zerstört das heißt die
ukraine braucht auch so eine relativ
banalen sachen wie treibstoff tanklaster
und ähnliches um den kampf zu
unterstützen ich glaube darauf sollten
wir uns konzentrieren und gucken dass es
darf auch angeht das ist ein gutes
beispiel denn die g7 staaten haben ja
auch eines erkannt die ukraine kann zum
beispiel keine renten mehr bezahlen und
das ist auch ganz wichtig wenn man nicht
sozusagen geld zur verfügung steht also
wenn man so will an verschiedenen
fronten muss gekämpft werden und auf
verschiedenen wegen muss eben
unterstützt werden vielen vielen dank
frau major das war sehr erhellen das war
sehr interessant was sie erklärt haben
und insofern haben wir vieles
dazugelernt durch dann wenn jasch und
eben auch sie vielen vielen dank und
grüße vielen dank
dankeschön
ja und das war unser zdf heute live zum
einen zur moral der russischen truppen
wie es um die soldaten steht und auch
eine weitergehende einordnung auch der
lage das ist mir jetzt sozusagen ganz
auf den aktuellen stand gekommen und
haben viele es nochmal eingeordnet
bekommen durch frau maja wir sagen
dankeschön für das interesse für die
vielen fragen wir hoffen dass wir die
antworten bekommen haben ihnen noch
einen schönen abend wir sogar wieder
sehen